بعد اسبوع من اعلان تحقيق التقدم من خلال
المحادثات مع الرئيس الفرنسي الامان
والماكرون في قمه المناخ وزيره الداخليه
البريطاما توقع مع نظيرها الفرنسي اتفاقا
لزياده الدوريات على الشواطئ الفرنسيه
بنسبه 40% بهدف منع المهاجرين من عبور
القناه الانجليزيه بموجب هذه الصفقه
الجديده سترفع الحكومه البريطانيه انفقها
على الدوريات ومعيدات المراقبه الى 63
مليون جنيه
الاشخاص الذين يعبرون القناه بشكل كبير
لقد كان رئيس الوزراء واضحا تماما وكنت
واضحه ايضا ان الهجره غير المشروعه لا
سيما في الاعداد التي رايناها مؤخرا غير
مقبوله تماما وهذا هو سبب وجود في باريس
اليوم للتوقيع على اتفاقيه التعاون
الجديده مع الفرنسيين لمعالجه هذه المشكله
سناك بدا متفائلا بالاتفاق خصوصا انه يسمح
للمره الاولى باستضافه فرنسا ضباط شرطه
بريطانيين كمراقبين للمساعده في تنسيق
وتبادل المعلومات حول شبكات تهريب البشر
لكن اريد ان اكون صريحا معا الناس اجراء
واحد لا يستطيع ان يحل المشكله بشكل سحريه
لا نستطيع فعل ذلك فجاه
انتقادات
الاتفاق فورا الاعلان عنه فمنظمه امن ستي
اعتبرت ان الاتفاق سيؤدي الى مزيد من
الرحلات الخطيره بسبب رفض بريطانيا القبول
بحصتها من طالب اللجوء فيما وصف حزب
العمال المعارض الاتفاق بانه ضعيف ومتاخر
في ان
مع توقيع الاتفاق الجديد مع فرنسا ووسط
تشديد الحكومه البريطانيه على عدم وجود
اجراء واحد لسيطره على الهجره غير
القانونيه لا يبدو ان مهمه سوناك وبرافما
ستكون سهله هذا ما يقوله المعارضون على
الاقل خصوصا مع وصول 40 الف مهاجرين هذا
العام مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن